Oh, I suppose I could try.
NOTE CONF
No, you can't do that on H2O.
Oh, that's a Who is here with me?
NOTE CONF
Last year Second semester last year, I was sat here
and I swear a couple of the faces are the
NOTE CONF
same from 3130, right?
It was in the same lecture, wasn't it?
NOTE CONF
I did not No, no, last year, I didn't teach
anything last session.
NOTE CONF
2nd semester last year.
Yeah, I'm having flashbacks.
NOTE CONF
I'm getting deja vu, but I think it's for a
real reason.
NOTE CONF
I'm standing in the same place, looking at the same
faces.
NOTE CONF
He had me for something, but, but particularly, it was
3130, and the people are probably sitting in the same
NOTE CONF
seats they said back then too, because of habit.
Alright, well let's get going.
NOTE CONF
G'day.
Uh, Matt Roberts, 3000.
NOTE CONF
This is a soft well, this is the last of
the software technology units, really, so most people here are,
NOTE CONF
you get to do it if you're enrolled in software
engineering, you're enrolled in BIT software technology, or if you've
NOTE CONF
chosen it as an Elective.
Um, the reason I point out that it's the last
NOTE CONF
of those units is it's kind of a capstoney unit
for the software technology stream, that being you come 1,000s,
NOTE CONF
10 10s, 2,000s, and 2010s, and yeah.
3000, um, also mixing in the distributed computing and the,
NOTE CONF
yeah you get the vibe, those kinds of units, it
kind of tries to wrap them all up.
NOTE CONF
In particular, it does flow in pretty heavily from 2000.
So if Come 2000 wasn't something that gelled with you.
NOTE CONF
Then you'll find a few pain points along the way
that you should be aware of.
NOTE CONF
Keep an eye out for them and just make sure
you ask for extra help at those times.
NOTE CONF
Don't just let yourself get swamped.
This is the key advice always.
NOTE CONF
Don't let yourself get swamped in computing units, things build
on other things and so it's very, it's harder to
NOTE CONF
recover.
Um, now if you do get swamped, still you try
NOTE CONF
and get yourself out of it.
The, the real key thing is not that you're gonna
NOTE CONF
probably need some help to get out of it because,
What you need is to fill in the particular gap
NOTE CONF
that you're missing maybe from an earlier unit, which is
not something you can work out yourself all that easily,
NOTE CONF
but it's something that the staff are rather good at.
Um, so when you're struggling with a topic where the
NOTE CONF
particular thing just makes no sense whatsoever, the.
Maybe not the first thing, but an early thing you
NOTE CONF
should do is come and talk to either Lucky or
myself or your class teacher, uh, because we can help
NOTE CONF
highlight what the underlying thing is that you're not getting.
Uh, and you can just brush up on that and
NOTE CONF
then you'll be good to go.
This particularly kicks in when we get to the evaluation
NOTE CONF
section of the course and we're effectively doing a visitor
pattern and so all the stuff from patterns, you have
NOTE CONF
to be, Yeah, pretty good with and then it's a
new pattern that you haven't learned before, and then the
NOTE CONF
way the objects talk to each other and the interaction
of that patterns.
NOTE CONF
There's a fair bit going on.
Uh, that with missing gaps can be troublesome.
NOTE CONF
I'm not trying to scare you.
I'm trying to get you to engage with the teaching
NOTE CONF
staff, cause that's what they're there to do, and they're
very good at it.
NOTE CONF
OK.
So, uh, oh I said Lucky, Lucky's not doing this,
NOTE CONF
it's just me.
I know Lucky is, Lucky.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let me run through the teaching stuff.
I'm teaching 2000 and 3000 this term and I'm mixing
NOTE CONF
them up because the teaching team is almost the same.
So let's hope I get this right.
NOTE CONF
Com 3000, I am lecturing.
You should see me here every week.
NOTE CONF
But the convenor is Lachlan Patrick.
Who I will call Lucky.
NOTE CONF
I don't have him on here probably because.
I know there is Lachlan's put himself there.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so I'll be doing, I guess most of the
teaching, but Lachlan is doing the administrative stuff.
NOTE CONF
Lachlan was in this place last year and I was
in his place last year, so there's no problem with
NOTE CONF
asking him questions you might want to ask me if
you just don't like me or my style.
NOTE CONF
Lachlan's there and he knows as much as me.
So you get 2 for the price of 1 in
NOTE CONF
that sense.
We also have our teaching assistants who run your workshop
NOTE CONF
classes.
They are of course welcome to answer your questions, but
NOTE CONF
for the The things outside of a workshop and the
things that are maybe Conceptually more difficult, Lachlan and I
NOTE CONF
are a good first port of call.
Um, mostly because you're, not because your teaching assistants aren't.
NOTE CONF
Capable, but because um they're paid to work in the
workshop classes and do the best job they can during
NOTE CONF
that two hour period, Lachlan and I are paid for
the broader view of things and where your teaching assistants
NOTE CONF
will definitely answer your questions, uh then they're doing it
on their own dime and if I'm getting paid, you
NOTE CONF
might as well ask me.
But again, if you don't like me or you don't
NOTE CONF
like Lachlan, they're there available um in case you need
their help.
NOTE CONF
It's OK.
I will sometimes try and keep this.
NOTE CONF
Open and keep an eye on it, but I'm terrible
at remembering to keep an eye on it.
NOTE CONF
So if you're listening in on the live stream, feel
free to try asking a question, but I can't guarantee
NOTE CONF
that I'll answer it.
It's just a bit hard to split your attention like
NOTE CONF
that when you're lecturing, even after practising it for a
long time.
NOTE CONF
If anyone in the audience sees a question on the
stream, they can just put up their hand and I'll
NOTE CONF
definitely see them cos they're here in the room.
But I do want this to be as accessible to
NOTE CONF
as many people as possible, so I will try.
If anyone's listening live on the stream.
NOTE CONF
But they're probably not, they're probably listening to the recording.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Let me just get fired up through some basics, shall
we?
NOTE CONF
Well, I've got my slides here, these will help me.
These are my slides, they're rather minimalist.
NOTE CONF
They're mostly just to keep me on track.
Um, so one of the things that'll happen when I'm
NOTE CONF
lecturing is you're not gonna get lecture slides.
Please put your hand up if that's a problem for
NOTE CONF
you.
I, I really do wanna know, yeah.
NOTE CONF
What's that?
Uh, what if you're not enrolled into a prat class?
NOTE CONF
That will become a problem rather quickly.
Is there a thing stopping you from getting enrolled, or?
NOTE CONF
They're all full.
OK, well, once they're full, other people open them.
NOTE CONF
Are they all full or just good ones full?
Then another one should be made available, but that happens
NOTE CONF
and now for the first week, this would officially be
Lachlan's decision, but I'm confident in this answer.
NOTE CONF
Attend another class, ask permission of the class teaching assistant.
You ask, so the, the general rule is you're welcome
NOTE CONF
in another class, ask and be aware they will, they
do have the discretion to turn you away if the
NOTE CONF
class is too busy for them to handle.
But that's never happened in my experience, but the power
NOTE CONF
always remains with the teaching assistant, you're not, they're not
obliged to accept you, but I've never had one turn
NOTE CONF
anyone away.
OK, especially while we wait for classes to open.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so that was a hands up, but not one
about missing slides, and you do have to tell me,
NOTE CONF
right?
Because my teaching styles might not match your learning style,
NOTE CONF
so you're not likely to get lecture slides unless you
ask them.
NOTE CONF
I'll explain why, so you might get a feel for
why, but it's nice to know early on, people who
NOTE CONF
think that might be troublesome for them, yeah.
Even better than that, yep, I'll get to that when
NOTE CONF
we get to the text, yep.
Am I going to write down what I'm going to
NOTE CONF
say was the question, and the answer is yes, everything
is written down.
NOTE CONF
But in by a slightly different mechanism.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
But again, I'm trying to be open to say please
talk to us if something's not working for you, including
NOTE CONF
me not providing normal PowerPoint slides.
OK, I've got this up here to keep me ticking
NOTE CONF
along in the direction I want to go and we've
got other materials that are really helpful, yes.
NOTE CONF
So if they're not slides, is there gonna be some
like.
NOTE CONF
will is not just Yes, yes, yes.
And in fact the course is built around it, but
NOTE CONF
I like that we're feeding into this, I like that
we're we're warming up to it.
NOTE CONF
You're thinking what's this material that's gonna be better than
my slides?
NOTE CONF
Let's get to it then.
It's this.
NOTE CONF
Don't be scared, it's a textbook, but it's a short
textbook.
NOTE CONF
So the reason I don't provide slides or summaries is
this is the most concise textbook I've ever seen.
NOTE CONF
There's nothing I would take out, you would just, I
would just be copying his headings and saying his words.
NOTE CONF
OK, so the slides in this course is the crafting
Interpreter's textbook freely available on the web.
NOTE CONF
OK, and we're typically working through like, 600 words a
week, like not a huge amount, like 2 pages written,
NOTE CONF
maybe, once you take out the code snippets.
Um, it's like I, I real, I know how horrible
NOTE CONF
it is to get a textbook where each week's material
is 40 pages and only 5 pages of it actually
NOTE CONF
relates to what the lecturer was talking about.
That's not this situation.
NOTE CONF
We are literally working through this textbook, front to back
as a part of the course.
NOTE CONF
Well, not front to back, front to halfway through.
As a part of the course.
NOTE CONF
So quite often during lectures I'll have this up and
I'll just be going through section by section to give
NOTE CONF
another expression to the same things he's saying in the
textbook.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that still may be a problem for some
people, this is not me saying, This is what you're
NOTE CONF
gonna deal with this, hopefully you'll be like, hopefully this
does end up working for most of you.
NOTE CONF
And with the wonderful world of uh Chatty G and
all our LLM friends, uh, if we really want slides,
NOTE CONF
we can pop this straight into Chatty G and ask
him to make slides for us and you can get
NOTE CONF
your own slides.
OK.
NOTE CONF
Which is what most of your lecturers are probably doing
anyway.
NOTE CONF
OK, so my slides are the What's going to happen
in the lecture that we're actually dealing with here, um,
NOTE CONF
and, Keep us on track.
OK, other questions?
NOTE CONF
I like questions.
More questions, the barrier.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
I've heard of the name Robert.
NOTE CONF
Well, he wrote another relatively famous book about game programming.
Um, or it could have just been me mentioning him
NOTE CONF
because I think he's great.
Uh, he's not super famous, but he has written a
NOTE CONF
couple of books.
And Ah design You probably bumped across Nystrom along along
NOTE CONF
the time, yes.
I read his graphics text book years ago and didn't
NOTE CONF
realise he was working in programming languages, which is my
field of research.
NOTE CONF
Um, and he's done a good job with this book.
OK.
NOTE CONF
Anything else?
Hm, I'll stop regularly for questions.
NOTE CONF
I'm sorry if it makes things a bit slow.
OK, so what's the unit about?
NOTE CONF
Well, the unit about is about writing your own programming
languages and.
NOTE CONF
Expanding your horizons on the number of programming languages you
can write for yourself.
NOTE CONF
It feels a bit like we're focusing on the first
one, how to write a.
NOTE CONF
Interpreter for a programming language.
But along the way we have to really properly understand
NOTE CONF
each of the constructs of that programming language.
And by doing that It opens up to us what
NOTE CONF
all the other programming languages do.
So from where you stand now, it might be tricky
NOTE CONF
to pick up an object system from another language.
But once you've implemented your own object system, all of
NOTE CONF
a sudden it's like, oh I get it, it's just
this variant on the thing I did.
NOTE CONF
As well as that, we teach creating your own language
through creating a brand new language.
NOTE CONF
And so obviously making a new language expands your horizons
a bit.
NOTE CONF
We're not creating an implementation of existing language.
To make one up.
NOTE CONF
So those are the two main goals here.
Don't get.
NOTE CONF
Tricked into thinking this is just a course on writing
interpreters and how interesting is writing interpreters.
NOTE CONF
Uh, it's a course on writing interpreters and using that
to expand your abilities as a programmer, to understand the
NOTE CONF
internals of programming languages and the systems that compile programmes.
And There was another part that just dropped out of
NOTE CONF
my head, it'll come back.
I know the leaning on comp 2000 stuff is because
NOTE CONF
it turns out the machinery we were giving you in
comp 2000.
NOTE CONF
is really important to this next step of writing what
is really a fairly I don't wanna call it complex
NOTE CONF
or substantial, but maybe substantial's the best word, a substantial
programme, an interpreter is a substantial programme.
NOTE CONF
So you make use in anger of a lot of
the features you might have just been playing with before
NOTE CONF
when writing Java code.
Because this course is in Java.
NOTE CONF
Just like all the software technology courses are in Java,
and we do ask you to please do your implementation
NOTE CONF
in Java.
We are tempted every year to open up the possibility
NOTE CONF
that you write it in another language, but every year
we decide that's not pedagogically, as in to do a
NOTE CONF
teaching, the right thing to do.
So the text uses Java and you should please use
NOTE CONF
Java.
In the modern day using Java can be quite a
NOTE CONF
lot of fun with all the fancy new features that
you haven't even learnt yet that are in Java.
NOTE CONF
Uh, Probably 16 through 21.
So if you're really desperate to use some fun fancy
NOTE CONF
programming language feature from your language of choice, we can
probably find a way to help you do that in
NOTE CONF
Java.
OK let's do a bit more of the Background, so
NOTE CONF
we've got a unit guide as always.
Which tells you to be frank, not a huge amount.
NOTE CONF
The real actions in the unit description here.
Using this acronym.
NOTE CONF
Uh, in this unit, which is gonna become, if you
haven't seen it already, you'll see more of it in
NOTE CONF
Faculty of Science and Engineering units.
It just means a unit that is, I don't know
NOTE CONF
how to describe it, it's just a unit like this
unit or a unit like GOM 2000.
NOTE CONF
A unit where you get something big and interesting to
do that's actually really related to what you're um gonna
NOTE CONF
do for work, and we try and make sure there's
teamwork and collaboration along the way, so you're not just
NOTE CONF
working solo.
Um, that's a whole style.
NOTE CONF
So 3000 is in that style, you're probably best come
to understand that style by actually doing comp 3000.
NOTE CONF
That's easier than just explaining it.
So what do I want to tell you?
NOTE CONF
Well, here's our um Here's our weekly activities.
13 weeks, every one of them gets used.
NOTE CONF
And the topics that we're doing focus on the content
and skills.
NOTE CONF
The activities won't make a giant amount of sense yet.
Oh, probably the other ones won't either, but week one,
NOTE CONF
we talk about team-based learning.
Week two, we talk about little languages, otherwise known as
NOTE CONF
domain-specific languages.
In week 3 we talk about los, which is the
NOTE CONF
brand new language you've never seen before that the textbook
writes an interpreter for.
NOTE CONF
So you get to learn a brand new language, it's
just a toy language in a sense, but it's got
NOTE CONF
some interesting features and it's the one that the textbook
progresses through.
NOTE CONF
So we spend a week learning that and then straight
into all of the ways, all of the different, Techniques
NOTE CONF
needed to write yourself an interpreter.
Scanning.
NOTE CONF
Grammars, pausing, evaluating, evaluating statements, control flow, functions, tricky things
in functions, even more tricky things in functions.
NOTE CONF
And by the end of it, we've got everything we
need to write our own compiler slash interpreter.
NOTE CONF
I'm using those words and you might not even properly
know what they mean yet.
NOTE CONF
We'll get that.
So these activities that you do in your workshop classes
NOTE CONF
directly, very directly relate to the two assignment submissions you
make.
NOTE CONF
Well, let's quickly go back to the unit guide and
just get that stuff out of the way.
NOTE CONF
Oh, we've done the old search routine.
So the things you really care about in the course
NOTE CONF
are, The assessment asks There's 2 submission points during semester
called assignment 1 and assignment 2, but they're both on
NOTE CONF
the same major project.
And then there's a final exam in the exam period.
NOTE CONF
Uh, both of those are.
You submit on iLarn a zip file or something.
NOTE CONF
Um, of your work, it's, uh, it's really key that
you know those are individual assessments.
NOTE CONF
Every assessment in this course is individual cos we're about
to start talking about teams in a big way.
NOTE CONF
But all assessments are individual.
Your work only.
NOTE CONF
I'll, I'll untie that knot in a minute.
Uh, we have the lectures which happen here on the
NOTE CONF
Monday, and then the material I talk about here gets
done in the workshops later during the week.
NOTE CONF
So I will talk about TBL team-based learning today, you
will do that in your workshops.
NOTE CONF
Next week, I will talk about, What was the first
topic?
NOTE CONF
Little languages, and then next you will do the little
languages in the following days.
NOTE CONF
Um The main thing is the textbook crafting interpreters.
Oh, on those two assessments, they're both.
NOTE CONF
So-called AI Open, which I'll go into a little bit
as well.
NOTE CONF
Well maybe we'll ask a few questions of you and
you ask a few questions of me, um.
NOTE CONF
One question I have straight up.
Is what do you know AI open to mean?
NOTE CONF
So, a little, the lectures are gonna go like this
a lot.
NOTE CONF
So I apologise for those who find it uncomfortable, but
it's just the way I do it, um.
NOTE CONF
allowed Allowed but what does not have to be declared.
OK, so it's a bit more that AI use is
NOTE CONF
allowed but still should be declared.
Uh, but does anyone else have a vibe on what
NOTE CONF
AI Open has meant?
No, yes.
NOTE CONF
A form, you fill out a form to say that
you used AI for this part, possibly.
NOTE CONF
These interpretations are very interesting to me.
OK lost Yeah, that's cool.
NOTE CONF
And this is the experience we have.
Not all students know, uh, have a Have a common
NOTE CONF
understanding of what that means, the main thing is to
have a common understanding.
NOTE CONF
I think I know what the real understanding is, but
all we care about in here is what Comp 3000's
NOTE CONF
understanding is.
3000's understanding is that you are not restricted from using
NOTE CONF
any tools you want.
OK, AI or otherwise, what's out there is yours to
NOTE CONF
use.
You should reference all tools and sources you use, including
NOTE CONF
AI, that's just standard academic practise.
OK, so there are basically no restrictions on your use,
NOTE CONF
which means as you're working through the assignment, you may
have a clawed code, go for it, just make sure
NOTE CONF
you tell us clawed code.
Was part of my assignment work.
NOTE CONF
So what's the downsides of this from your point of
view?
NOTE CONF
What's that?
Lack of learning, good, that's a very good one.
NOTE CONF
I'll address each, but I want to get as many
as I can.
NOTE CONF
Any other downsides we can think of?
coils.
NOTE CONF
valuable tasks.
The potential and perhaps the temptation to outsource things that
NOTE CONF
are really valuable to you but maybe tedious to get
the AI to do them, yes.
NOTE CONF
Mhm.
Traps Code for something and Yeah, you might end up
NOTE CONF
making code A that doesn't work very well, and then
when it doesn't work very well, you don't really understand
NOTE CONF
it to fix it, do you?
Correct.
NOTE CONF
OK, these are all good and common downsides, I think
they are all things that you should watch out for.
NOTE CONF
The overall answer to that is we're designing our assessments
to help you avoid that, maybe you'll see that when
NOTE CONF
we get to a bit more detail on the assessment,
but what are the upsides that you think from having
NOTE CONF
this approach?
I know that Where they are located.
NOTE CONF
Mhm.
Ask questions.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, so you're saying I'm using you as a mentor,
as a personal tutor, and I would read into that
NOTE CONF
you don't have to worry about how you choose to
use it.
NOTE CONF
What works for you, you just get to do.
And I Because with the alternative.
NOTE CONF
I But if you get stuck on something, it's kind
of like an enhanced like an enhanced search engine is
NOTE CONF
always.
Uh Yep, enhanced search engine has the ability to tutor
NOTE CONF
you, yes.
There's no arguing that in the used the right way,
NOTE CONF
it's very powerful, so that's I guess the logic from
the university's point of view.
NOTE CONF
That this should be allowed because it's a powerful tool
if he's right.
NOTE CONF
The worry from most people is that it's a powerful
tool that's mostly used wrong.
NOTE CONF
But, uh, we'll talk, I, I hope you'll see that
we have.
NOTE CONF
Created something that will work out, I'd love for you
to feed back to us as you go.
NOTE CONF
Uh, where we can improve.
Obviously this is new to everyone, so if you do
NOTE CONF
think, oh come on man, I.
Then just let us know.
NOTE CONF
We won't be changing this term semester, it's all set,
but it'll help the people in the future, um, unless
NOTE CONF
there's something egregious that we will change.
OK, so you're gonna see soon the way we work
NOTE CONF
our way around that.
So your overall job actually is to make a brand
NOTE CONF
new programming language for a specific task and the the,
Outline highlights that that task has got something to do
NOTE CONF
with River flows Um, we'll get to it in a
coup, we'll see it soon, but we're making a brand
NOTE CONF
new programming language that allows people to model and, Both
model in terms of describe and then model in terms
NOTE CONF
of see how they operate in real life.
River systems.
NOTE CONF
You can imagine this is an important thing for Australians
who have only a couple of gigantic rivers that are
NOTE CONF
sucked dry every year.
Knowing where water goes and how it gets there is
NOTE CONF
very important.
So we'll be creating a tool that water managers might
NOTE CONF
be able to use to help them understand how, Water
gets into and through their rivers.
NOTE CONF
Brand new programming language.
But built in exactly the same style as the language
NOTE CONF
Locks, which is the one Nystrom builds in his book.
So you'll be reading through Nystrom's book and he's implementing
NOTE CONF
locks and at the same time, you'll be working through
your own programming language and implementing whatever you've decided to
NOTE CONF
call your river management language.
OK.
NOTE CONF
No, I did the same thing.
I had to put mine on do not disturb before.
NOTE CONF
OK, questions, thoughts, yep.
Sorry, where can you find There is a website version.
NOTE CONF
So the book is Crafting Interpreters, I just looked that
up.
NOTE CONF
I think there's a link on iLearn.
online There might not be a link on iland yet,
NOTE CONF
so we'll put a link on island.
Um, but yeah, it's just, it's crafting Interpreters.com.
NOTE CONF
You know, You read it online, we've got a couple
of copy paper copies in the library for those who
NOTE CONF
prefer that.
I must admit it was a very dodgy print on
NOTE CONF
demand service, they're not great copies.
I really wish there could be a better copy.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
In the a guy, thank you.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
That's it, yep, we're reading now down the bottom of
NOTE CONF
the crafting interpreter site.
And on the unit guide is where the link is.
NOTE CONF
Thank you.
OK, other questions structure, I hope there are a few
NOTE CONF
questions because this is probably not.
OK We're comfortable, we're happy.
NOTE CONF
We've made our way through the unit guide, we know
that there are individual assessments.
NOTE CONF
AI open, which means unrestricted use of AI but do
reference it.
NOTE CONF
There is a key, um, Wart in the open AI
system, which is that plagiarism rules still apply.
NOTE CONF
You, it's still academic dishonesty to take somebody else's work
and present some other human's work and present it as
NOTE CONF
your own.
It's now perfectly fine to take a machine's work and
NOTE CONF
present it as your own, but it's not OK to
take another human's work and present it as its own.
NOTE CONF
To be honest, in the age of AI Open where
you can use the tools to get as much help
NOTE CONF
as you want, I can't see a good reason to
be copying from friends anyway, yes.
NOTE CONF
Final exam, you see AIF.
Yes.
NOTE CONF
that is the Macquarie Uni word for you can't use
AI.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So there are 2 types of assessments at Macquarie, open
NOTE CONF
and observed.
In an open assessment, you should expect unrestricted ability to
NOTE CONF
use AI.
In an observed one, you should expect some type of
NOTE CONF
restriction.
If it's an exam, it just means you're in an
NOTE CONF
exam hall.
No use.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, exactly.
OK, so I mean that's one thing about the lack
NOTE CONF
of learning here is that there's a 50% exam at
the end.
NOTE CONF
That that that's a fair chunk of motivation to actually
learn what's going on.
NOTE CONF
Yeah OK, so let me fill in a few more
parts just, well, when I'm gonna get to 10 piece
NOTE CONF
lady.
I'm just trying to work out the right way to
NOTE CONF
do this.
Now, I'm gonna do the.
NOTE CONF
The team thing first.
OK, so we've talked about what's individual.
NOTE CONF
But the entire unit is somehow team-based.
So I'm just gonna untangle the knot about the team-based
NOTE CONF
and individual assessment for the assignment.
You're gonna be working on those assignments, on that major
NOTE CONF
work, all semester in a team.
And then you're going to be making individual submissions at
NOTE CONF
submission time.
We will explicitly tell you, you may use as much
NOTE CONF
of your teammates' work as you want.
In your submission.
NOTE CONF
So Do you ah how am I saying, it's it's,
it's untangling, you're doing work in a group.
NOTE CONF
But you're submitting individually.
But because you're free to copy your teammates' work, You
NOTE CONF
could all just submit the same thing, but you're making
individual submissions, yes.
NOTE CONF
uh.
And that's exact, yeah, that's exactly what we aim for.
NOTE CONF
We aim for you to have a common pool of
work, I'll repeat this for the people on the stream.
NOTE CONF
The team creates a common pool of work from which
you can draw your submission.
NOTE CONF
And when you see the rubric, there will be an
item that says have you extended your team's work?
NOTE CONF
You will get more grades for that.
I just want to say I, I was very confused
NOTE CONF
by the structural.
Yes, so We're reusing it from 2000 here and com
NOTE CONF
3000, so com 2000 and 3000 both do the same
thing now, so if you've done 2000 last semester.
NOTE CONF
Most, you would have come across the same thing and
we're doing the exact same thing in 3000 this time.
NOTE CONF
And we did it in 3000 last semester too, so
we know that it works.
NOTE CONF
Pretty well.
So, yes.
NOTE CONF
20 The nuclear 0, 2010's a prerequisite as well.
Yes, yes, so put your hand up if you've done
NOTE CONF
2010 instead of 2000.
Cool, and that's about what it normally is, it's, it
NOTE CONF
is crucial.
Well, no, no, no, the 2000 is not crucial.
NOTE CONF
The there's a reason we made that prerequisite.
So, uh, 2010 was the other one, right?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
We hope you've picked up, well, we're almost certain you've
NOTE CONF
picked up the same skills in 2010.
But 2000 was the place where we really pushed on
NOTE CONF
them.
Ah, then you'll be 100% fine.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I Um, how that You just ask us and we
NOTE CONF
help you.
We're great at that.
NOTE CONF
Yeah OK.
Um So nods or shakes, does that assignment situation make
NOTE CONF
sense to you, at least somewhat?
OK, it will become a little bit clearer as things
NOTE CONF
go on.
But all of the workshops are team-based, like really quite.
NOTE CONF
Have you done, who, who did 2000 last semester of
last year?
NOTE CONF
Semester 2 last year, right, so I think it was
similar, I wasn't actually enrolled in 2000.
NOTE CONF
So I think you'll find the class is similar to
that.
NOTE CONF
Um, can anyone describe what that was like?
Is anyone willing who was there?
NOTE CONF
Did you do 2000 last year?
No, I'm pointing at.
NOTE CONF
You did.
Can you tell us what it was like?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
We go out Mhm Like what this time.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but the actual workshop classrooms, how did they run?
Uh Was the first week.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
That's what we're doing here again, yes, so.
NOTE CONF
I'll, I'll go through and describe that to you.
Well, let's learn what team-based learning is.
NOTE CONF
I got a video.
That's why I went to all that trouble to do
NOTE CONF
the audio.
You know, it's Macquarie because of the colour scheme.
NOTE CONF
This is what she's At least the stock footage is
actually of Macquarie.
NOTE CONF
I didn't need the sans.
That's a bit quick.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, depends on which lab, if you're in for RPD
you're fine, but.
NOTE CONF
This was made in general for general classes, we were,
all of yours I think are in a lab.
NOTE CONF
Expect to see some high fives.
There probably won't be a debate.
NOTE CONF
Right.
OK, so it's got that title team-based learning it that.
NOTE CONF
You should think of that really just as a a
a.
NOTE CONF
Trendy title for a class that runs in this particular
style, and the style is, As I said, I'm just
NOTE CONF
gonna say the same thing again but in my own
words and relate it more to 3000.
NOTE CONF
You get some pre-work, pre-class work to do, which is
readings and we're coming to a lecture, I'll say most
NOTE CONF
of the things in the lecture and then there'll be
a chapter of the textbook that's related to that.
NOTE CONF
So everything's either in that chapter of the textbook and
all the words I say in the lecture.
NOTE CONF
Then you attend class and the first thing that happens
in class is you sit down by yourself and you
NOTE CONF
do a little multiple choice quiz, just by yourself, solo.
As soon as that's done.
NOTE CONF
You jump into your team, that is the same team
you've been in, you're you're in all term.
NOTE CONF
And you all do the same multiple choice questions, which
feels like a bit of a waste of time, but
NOTE CONF
isn't at all, because these questions always bring up discussion
in the team to come up with the right answer.
NOTE CONF
So at the end of that, each team, the whole
class will then go through the same multiple choice questions
NOTE CONF
and each team will say what they think their answer
is.
NOTE CONF
If there's agreement, we just move straight on.
If there's some discussion to be had, the discussion is
NOTE CONF
had, that's the clarification session.
And all that takes about 40 minutes and is great.
NOTE CONF
It's a really good way to learn, like, as soon
as you've done it, you'll be like, oh this is
NOTE CONF
brilliant, I don't know why all my classes aren't like
this.
NOTE CONF
It's the first time I heard about it I'm like
that is so arbitrary, I've seen so many.
NOTE CONF
Teaching styles that just seem made up, but it works
really well.
NOTE CONF
Uh, as soon as, when that's done, you then get
given a task that really should, could only be done
NOTE CONF
in a team.
It's not quite true, it's a bit hard in computing.
NOTE CONF
But we give you a task specifically designed that your
team can get it done in an hour or a
NOTE CONF
little bit more.
And that task is very closely related to your assignment.
NOTE CONF
It's probably something that exactly will appear in your assignment.
It will move your assignment forward, like we will be
NOTE CONF
giving you, please do some work on your river language
during these hours, and your team will work on it
NOTE CONF
together, but there'll be a specific focus that you're aiming
for that week.
NOTE CONF
And then at the end of that period, 15 to
20 minutes will be used so that each team can
NOTE CONF
explain to the class the way they got to the
solution for that specific.
NOTE CONF
Task OK, and every class should go the same.
Questions, thoughts.
NOTE CONF
Yep Closes, um, build up Yes.
Classes are building on previous weeks and the content and
NOTE CONF
your, your language that you're building is building through.
Now, here's one of the big advantages of team-based learning,
NOTE CONF
you're in the team.
I persistent through the term.
NOTE CONF
The team is in your class.
It's 5 other people or 4 other people from your
NOTE CONF
class.
If you miss a week, it is so much easier
NOTE CONF
to catch up because you just turn up next week
and someone from your team catches you up, or they
NOTE CONF
just ping you on WhatsApp over the week and help
you catch up.
NOTE CONF
Like it's so much more support available for the study,
just having 4 or 5 other people who you are
NOTE CONF
talking to in class every week, the same 4 or
5 people.
NOTE CONF
Um, classes are not compulsory, but.
Part of the assessment rubric does include.
NOTE CONF
Um, well, it's the logbook submissions, I'll, we'll get to
that.
NOTE CONF
So classes are not compulsory, you can definitely just miss
a few no special considerations required and catch up afterwards.
NOTE CONF
But it.
The team needs you there, so they're compulsory in that
NOTE CONF
sense.
These aren't classes where we go, oh turn up or
NOTE CONF
don't turn up, whatever we want.
These are classes where we say turn up unless you've
NOTE CONF
got a good reason.
Your team will kick you out.
NOTE CONF
Like you will get kicked out of your team if
you don't turn up.
NOTE CONF
And then you'll have no team and no support for
your assignment, which is not good.
NOTE CONF
Uh, that's a key point though because if you're in
an awkward class, this isn't working for you, make the
NOTE CONF
effort to change it.
If you're in a class and you think, oh maybe
NOTE CONF
I'll just work every second week, no, chuck that shift
out the window, um, find another one.
NOTE CONF
You do want, like it is.
Compulsory to be in every class.
NOTE CONF
So I'll talk a bit, uh, fingers crossed I'm not
mixing up 2000 and 3000 here.
NOTE CONF
So for the next, for my entire discussion on logbooks.
I'm going to put a little asterisk next to it
NOTE CONF
to say keep an eye on the forum in case
I've accidentally said something that's true of one unit and
NOTE CONF
not the other.
But each week in your workshop, you should write out
NOTE CONF
a little, uh we want you to keep a logbook
of your activity during the workshop class.
NOTE CONF
This is just a good study technique and a good
professional technique.
NOTE CONF
Is to have a logbook of your work.
Every For me personally, every day I write down what
NOTE CONF
I do.
I have two types.
NOTE CONF
My logbook goes from both directions.
My logbook is every day is in my logbook and
NOTE CONF
when I've got a to do, it goes in the
logbook ahead of time.
NOTE CONF
And when it's done, I write down what I did
in the logbook behind time, and that means I can
NOTE CONF
go back in history and see what I've done and
see decisions I've made and why I've made those decisions
NOTE CONF
because I'm writing little notes on each item.
So it's not just arbitrary, it's a professional and study
NOTE CONF
skill to keep a logbook and in this unit we'll
be asking you to keep a logbook of your time
NOTE CONF
in your workshop classes.
It can be electronic, it can be paper, it can
NOTE CONF
be whatever works for you, yep.
We won't be using GitHub Classroom, no.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
We will not be doing that in conflict.
NOTE CONF
Yes, is there another question?
It's never really happened, but Like, people don't actually have
NOTE CONF
to kick people out, but the, the point I'm trying
to make is that, uh, during this first week, the
NOTE CONF
team will write a little contract that says what you
expect of everybody.
NOTE CONF
And so what tends to happen is that teams come
to us a couple of weeks later and say we
NOTE CONF
haven't seen this person in 3 weeks.
And we say, OK, there's a person over there who's
NOTE CONF
not getting on with their team, they can join you,
just forget about that person.
NOTE CONF
And uh we just, thecha just changes and this person
never, they get an email from their teammates going, we
NOTE CONF
got someone else cos you weren't turning up and that's
it.
NOTE CONF
It's not like a big process.
The teams deal with it themselves, but like.
NOTE CONF
It's built into the, like we built into our, our
frame of mind about how our teams are operating is
NOTE CONF
that yeah, yeah, you're you're not stuck with someone who's
not contributing.
NOTE CONF
Right.
Uh, yeah.
NOTE CONF
That's my dragon fork there a little bit.
Let's just back up a little.
NOTE CONF
What was I talking about?
Yes.
NOTE CONF
You, you've got me back on track.
So, you're keeping these logbooks every week.
NOTE CONF
If you skip a week, like you miss a week
and you get through the next week, you should catch
NOTE CONF
up on the work and do a little logbook entry
for it.
NOTE CONF
And we would like you to get those logbooks, like
just show your teacher at the end of class, because
NOTE CONF
one of the rubric items in the assignment is going
to be.
NOTE CONF
Logbook entries And if you have logbook entries of any
form, you might get a couple marks.
NOTE CONF
If you have logbook entries that were done all through
semester.
NOTE CONF
And that your teacher saw, you will get full marks.
And that's, I think it's might be 15% of the
NOTE CONF
assessment, maybe 20%, not a giant chunk.
Not, not of the whole course, I mean of the
NOTE CONF
assessment section.
But it's substantial.
NOTE CONF
So keeping that logbook is a a relatively simple thing
to do when you're attending class because we're only looking
NOTE CONF
for like a few notes, they're not expensive.
And um Then they get submitted with your assignment submission
NOTE CONF
just like as if they were kind of a reflection
that you've already written.
NOTE CONF
But the other key part, keep your hand up so
I don't forget you, but the other key part is
NOTE CONF
that your teachers will give you feedback based on what's
in that logbook.
NOTE CONF
You get timely feedback instead of having to wait.
We only got these hopeless 3 submissions now.
NOTE CONF
This way you've got 13 possible submission points directly related
to your assignment where you can write things down.
NOTE CONF
You can send it to your teacher and say, can
you look at this and give me like doesn't have
NOTE CONF
to be 10 seconds feedback, you say, can you give
me some feedback on this and they can think about
NOTE CONF
it and send that back to you, you've got a
mechanism for getting feedback through a semester, yes.
NOTE CONF
So we Correct, well, yes, uh, the rubrics, because this
is a little bit wavy, we're gonna get the rubrics
NOTE CONF
out super early, maybe next week.
You're not gonna be waiting until weeks 5 or 6
NOTE CONF
to find out the rubrics for the two assignments and
then you'll see directly.
NOTE CONF
What it is, yeah.
I think the timeliness of the local gantries will be
NOTE CONF
more important than the quality of the local gantries.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
OK, yep.
Oh yeah, I don't know if we've got one of
NOTE CONF
those.
So the question was, do we have a collective unit
NOTE CONF
email address like 3000@mq instead of um emailing us.
I don't know actually.
NOTE CONF
Good question.
I'll write that in my logbook.
NOTE CONF
And I'll get lucky to answer it on the forums.
OK, so, hit me up with what you think might
NOTE CONF
be some problems with this, there's two parts here.
The team-based learning overall, and then the way we're stitching
NOTE CONF
it together with your assignments.
You can think of some problems.
NOTE CONF
With this approach, yes.
Well, if you say we That's a great point.
NOTE CONF
If your work, if your team does the work correctly,
how can you make an extension to get the extra
NOTE CONF
marks?
Uh, you're gonna see it directly in the assignment spec.
NOTE CONF
because we're writing a programming language to solves, there's infinitely
many extensions.
NOTE CONF
This is a really open-ended task right from the start.
There's gonna be big variations in everyone's work.
NOTE CONF
It's not something where there's one correct answer.
So there definitely will be.
NOTE CONF
You add a question next.
Yeah, Yeah, yeah, so the competitiveness, you're like, I gotta
NOTE CONF
keep something in, in the bank because I want to
get that full marks and if I share it with
NOTE CONF
my team, they've got it, I've gotta do something else
extra.
NOTE CONF
That's theoretically a problem that we haven't seen in practise.
So I will just write that down as something to
NOTE CONF
keep an eye on because you're right, maybe we tweak
our rubric a little bit just to take the pressure
NOTE CONF
off that.
I'll go there and then there, yeah.
NOTE CONF
Well, I want to expand on that because if the,
the, the criteria is that you expand on your team's
NOTE CONF
work, the work that you.
Apply to It's uh Everyone says the same thing.
NOTE CONF
really Then you can be marked an ambitious.
Yeah, so Ah, good, uh.
NOTE CONF
Uh Uh The uh Uh TR changed very much I
not so much discussion because We ask us like uh
NOTE CONF
which one does.
Uh, part of it is like mostly.
NOTE CONF
Mhm Yes, so we've, we've learned from that experience to
make more ambiguous questions, um, but on the point of,
NOTE CONF
Feeding into the, the submission and identifying your own work.
Um, How can I describe this?
NOTE CONF
There's a lot more in the submission than just the
code.
NOTE CONF
We're we're gonna ask for you to submit the code
and then answer some questions about the code and.
NOTE CONF
That is where you're gonna feel, you're gonna feel quite
confident that you're individually marking doing the assignment.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna feel a bit like I'm submitting my team's
work and I'm submitting my answer to the questions that
NOTE CONF
they've just given me on my team's work.
So It's not gonna feel that we're digging through the
NOTE CONF
source code trying to find out who's who's who.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
NOTE CONF
OK, back, was there another one back up there?
Yeah, cool.
NOTE CONF
OK, good, and please keep these questions coming.
As I say, the full assignment's gonna be released way
NOTE CONF
earlier than you expect, like for the whole semester and
we'll be able to iron out.
NOTE CONF
Thoughts and questions that you're having about it, but I'm
confident because we did the same thing last year, and
NOTE CONF
we got a really interesting set of things, yes.
No, we don't need minutes in the team-based learning, no.
NOTE CONF
Just to, and actually this is a good point, I
noticed it in the class I did this morning.
NOTE CONF
The logbook is a personal logbook, not a team logbook.
So think of it more like a support group for
NOTE CONF
your study, the 4 of you have been stuck, or
5 or 6 of you have been jammed together to
NOTE CONF
study this unit together.
More my study group, more than like what you might
NOTE CONF
think of as a group project where now you're all
relying on each other and they've got to do this
NOTE CONF
part and I've got to do this part, it's much
more like what was that TV show Community, like that.
NOTE CONF
You've just been jammed into a study group.
No pain.
NOTE CONF
Well, we'll see.
We might have Dungeons and Dragons, but no paintball.
NOTE CONF
OK.
specialised Oh, I wrote FA and SSE here, um, application
NOTE CONF
exercise.
You might hear me referring to it as FA, just
NOTE CONF
as an acronym matches with RAT.
What was my Full application task or something, I had
NOTE CONF
an acronym for it, but anyway, that just means the
application task, the main one hour thing that you do
NOTE CONF
together as a team.
Um, now SSE, Every week we will submit for you,
NOTE CONF
you will also get self-study exercises.
This diagram comes from another course, but, but from the
NOTE CONF
new version of CM 2000, but I'm gonna show you
anyway.
NOTE CONF
Uh Cause it applies just the same here.
No, no.
NOTE CONF
Don't use the back button in iLearn.
I'll probably try and get this um.
NOTE CONF
This little picture up for you guys as well.
But this picture applies in this course as well.
NOTE CONF
Where The exam is actually the theoretical material of the
course and the assignments is the practical material of the
NOTE CONF
course.
That's why it's fifty-fifty split.
NOTE CONF
And along the way obviously you're learning a lot of
the theoretical material by doing the assignment, but you're not
NOTE CONF
learning it well enough to sit an exam on the
material.
NOTE CONF
So each week, like we don't try and mix the
workshops into partly theoretical, partly practical, they're just full practical,
NOTE CONF
full team based, full experiential thing.
And the theoretical sit down and grind out some study
NOTE CONF
time, just keep separately in what we call the self-study.
Every week a set of self-study exercises are made available
NOTE CONF
for that.
T They might have some value for your workshop and
NOTE CONF
assignment stuff, but they'll have much more value for the
final exam.
NOTE CONF
So don't neglect them because they're not happening in workshop
classes, we are really splitting that practical and theoretical thing.
NOTE CONF
That's one of the downsides of team-based learning.
Is that it's so it's so much of an experience
NOTE CONF
and a team-based thing that that kind of deep thinking
can't happen.
NOTE CONF
There's like that solo focus on something can't happen in
one of those classes.
NOTE CONF
So we want you to do that in your self-study
time through the self-study exercises which are published every week.
NOTE CONF
So that takes you back to where I was before,
which was asking about upsides and downsides of things.
NOTE CONF
Um, we were on downsides of team-based learning and the
assignment kind of setup.
NOTE CONF
Do we have any other downsides?
There's one conspicuous one I can think of, yeah.
NOTE CONF
In the work.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So if you've got a team that's not great, you
can fall back.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, we've, that's something we're worried about.
What we've seen in practise.
NOTE CONF
So, so the, the classroom teachers are gonna be prepared
for that situation and if they see someone who's in
NOTE CONF
a team of people doing nothing and they're the only
one doing stuff, they're probably gonna shift onto a team.
NOTE CONF
another team.
Um, but what they're looking out for is someone who's
NOTE CONF
not.
Learning.
NOTE CONF
So if you're managing to learn with a dodgy team.
They might leave you alone and if you really want
NOTE CONF
to get moved you might have to ask rather than
be proactive about it.
NOTE CONF
But as I say, this is our 3rd time round,
it hasn't come up huge huge, but we're aware of
NOTE CONF
it and again this is about learning more than it
is about matching to a structure.
NOTE CONF
There's a related one to that.
There's a downside that someone's got to be thinking of
NOTE CONF
because they keep asking you questions.
How do you feel right now, now I'm asking you
NOTE CONF
a question?
That's the feeling you're gonna have in a team-based learning
NOTE CONF
class.
You can't avoid getting involved, so if you're shy, if
NOTE CONF
you just want to sit there quietly, it's not going
to feel the most comfortable at the start of the
NOTE CONF
semester.
Um, I'm gonna encourage you and I encourage the teaching
NOTE CONF
staff to do the same with you, to get over
that hurdle as fast as possible, so that it can
NOTE CONF
be a lively experience for you.
And we recognise that that can be uncomfortable.
NOTE CONF
I when I discuss this with learning designers, I'm like,
I'm increasing the stress of my students, surely that gets
NOTE CONF
in the way of their learning.
And they're like, well, try it and see, and it
NOTE CONF
doesn't seem to increase it too much.
Definitely increases it more in the first couple of weeks.
NOTE CONF
So my advice is A, get a like work hard
on it in the first few weeks to get through
NOTE CONF
that discomfort, you'll find a greener pastures on the other
side.
NOTE CONF
But my offer or my safety net is if it's
just not you.
NOTE CONF
You don't have to.
Talk to me and or Lucky, rather than the class
NOTE CONF
teacher because the class teacher's focused on trying to make
teams work, um, and just say this is just not
NOTE CONF
gonna work for me.
I, for one reason or another, just it's gonna be
NOTE CONF
impossible for me to learn under these situations.
And we will find something, we'll make it work for
NOTE CONF
you.
OK, so nobody is forced into this situation, but everybody
NOTE CONF
is encouraged to fight through it at least a little
bit.
NOTE CONF
Make sense?
OK Thank you.
NOTE CONF
And in the past we have had some people, it
just hasn't worked for them and they've ended up doing
NOTE CONF
just fine in the course.
Quite often what they like to do is just attend
NOTE CONF
the class, listen to everybody else, but not have to
say anything.
NOTE CONF
There's a, if you think about what we described in
that class, lots of people, students are getting up and
NOTE CONF
explaining what they've learned.
There's big value in that for the person who gets
NOTE CONF
up and explains, but there's also value for the people
who are listening.
NOTE CONF
OK.
Alright, look at us, look at us on time.
NOTE CONF
I've got my little timing things down the bottom, can
you see?
NOTE CONF
It's very helpful.
OK, so that's the The structure of the course, the
NOTE CONF
ins and outs, we're going to get into actual.
Well, I guess we've got started on the material as
NOTE CONF
well cos we've done the team-based learning stuff.
Is that everything I want you to know about team-based
NOTE CONF
learning?
No, there's more, I'm gonna go back to the team-based
NOTE CONF
learning.
OK.
NOTE CONF
I mean that's mechanically what team-based learning is about, but
let me explain why it even works.
NOTE CONF
And why it'll probably work, it should work well in
3000.
NOTE CONF
Oh, got foreign posts.
OK, um, Yes.
NOTE CONF
Yes, I think that's a very good point.
So the point that was made was that uh the
NOTE CONF
teams working on this code base together, various teammates, uh,
team members could be contributing code from open, from AI
NOTE CONF
sources and then Another member tries to understand it, they've
got no one to ask.
NOTE CONF
What does this code mean?
I think the fact that we do so much of
NOTE CONF
the assignment, like the the team code, that base that
you worked on like you described, you've got a base
NOTE CONF
that you can build off, so much of that is
basically those one hour sessions in class.
NOTE CONF
And so if people are introducing There's not a lot
of the team-based.
NOTE CONF
Well, in my experience, I'd say most teams do about
80% of their work in the classroom.
NOTE CONF
It's not like a group assignment where someone sends you
some work on a Tuesday afternoon to fill in the
NOTE CONF
gap.
You're coming together each week, working on it for an
NOTE CONF
hour and maybe doing bits and pieces around that.
But the bulk is that together time where, even if
NOTE CONF
it is involved, you're all sitting around doing it together.
But still, it's definitely something to keep an eye out
NOTE CONF
for.
And this is, we weren't open for AI last year,
NOTE CONF
so the rules are slightly different, and we should keep
an eye on that, see how it works out for
NOTE CONF
the students.
Oh well that's a quick rundown, uh, who codes with
NOTE CONF
a coding agent to help them these days?
I do.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
OK, so who doesn't use coding agents to help them
NOTE CONF
code?
OK.
NOTE CONF
Well, I'm not, I, I would encourage you to, I
choose to use a coding agent to help me code.
NOTE CONF
It's a very good um.
What's the one I'm looking for?
NOTE CONF
Recently I had an experience where I was trying to
make.
NOTE CONF
Yeah As from Very Uh, like a Python script that
would take.
NOTE CONF
Uh, a CSP table that I can fill out and.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
I I understand Those experiences like Because I Yes.
Yes, in other cases I have it in reverse where
NOTE CONF
I'm writing.
Have Yes, I think those, I mean, I won't repeat
NOTE CONF
that whole thing for the people on the slide, but.
We're at this kind of cusp right now where some
NOTE CONF
people are a bit anti it and choosing not to
use it, and other people are overly pro it and
NOTE CONF
just do it for everything.
Um, it feels like this semester more than any others,
NOTE CONF
it might be a good chance for us as a
group.
NOTE CONF
To talk about how each of us is using it
to understand from each other the pros and the cons.
NOTE CONF
Um, so I might do that a bit in the
lectures as a way to prompt those discussions, but also
NOTE CONF
in workshops, I'm hoping you can see the way other
people are using the tools and get your own judgement
NOTE CONF
about whether you like or dislike it, yeah?
What would I, uh, recommend for coding?
NOTE CONF
Well, me personally, I'm using OpenCode.
Which is an open source clawed code rip off that
NOTE CONF
doesn't charge you money.
It's potentially not as good at writing code, but I'm
NOTE CONF
very good at writing code, so I don't, I don't
feel that that's a problem.
NOTE CONF
Um, and it has been very good at, it has
been perfectly good at doing the things I want it
NOTE CONF
to do.
Yeah Yeah, it uses free models that and the, the
NOTE CONF
quality of the answers you go up and down because
you don't know which model they're giving you.
NOTE CONF
You don't know who they're giving your data to either,
so be aware of that.
NOTE CONF
But um.
Like the various LLMs are roughly.
NOTE CONF
On a single level.
Mhm.
NOTE CONF
Yeah What really changes the quality of experience is often
be.
NOTE CONF
Uh The environment that The tooling around the LM is
what makes a big difference, yes.
NOTE CONF
Yeah On us, uh, that's.
A harness makes a big difference.
NOTE CONF
So I think if you haven't used it, I mean,
I have this OpenCode's the one I've used most.
NOTE CONF
I haven't used Cloud code much.
I've used Codex.
NOTE CONF
Um, but the thing that Open code strongly encourages you
to do is to go in and out of plan
NOTE CONF
and build mode.
You spend most of your time in plan mode where
NOTE CONF
you're talking to the LLM back and forth about various
decisions, and then once you're happy with what it says
NOTE CONF
it wants to do, you flip into build mode and
it starts to do things on your computer.
NOTE CONF
Just having a tool that started me off in plan
mode changed the way I interacted with the LLMs a
NOTE CONF
fair bit, and that's what you're saying about the tooling
and the harnessing around it.
NOTE CONF
Changing what happens, yeah.
Because I think one thing like anthropics, others, I don't
NOTE CONF
know if there are any like.
Better They Right, yeah, it's a toy.
NOTE CONF
OK, right, there's not like how, how they.
Yeah Yeah, so I can't tell one from another.
NOTE CONF
Are there people, and I should ask this now, do
you have anyone got a moral objection, and there were
NOTE CONF
reasonable moral objections.
The LLM use.
NOTE CONF
So if, if there's a moral objection and you just
don't want to be talking about it too much in
NOTE CONF
class.
Now's the time to put your hand up so that
NOTE CONF
I can know to be a bit more sensitive of
people's cos it is quite a for for my friends
NOTE CONF
who have moral objections to it, there are faculty here
at the university, they crack the they get so annoyed
NOTE CONF
that every meeting has people talking about LLMs and all
they want to do is put up their hands and
NOTE CONF
go.
Burning, like they're using all the water and they stole
NOTE CONF
all of our information and all their moral objections just
fill their head and they can't be a part of
NOTE CONF
the discussion.
So, so if you're finding yourself in that situation, you
NOTE CONF
just ask me to tone it down.
I understand, I understand that there are big moral objections.
NOTE CONF
OK.
So I was going in a bit more to the
NOTE CONF
TBL.
So the pre-class work was relatively easy, ah, what was
NOTE CONF
the reasons for these kinds of things that we do?
OK.
NOTE CONF
So Just pedag I'll use that word again, pedagogically, but
it means from the perspective of learning the material rather
NOTE CONF
than the material itself.
This process works because it asks you to individually address
NOTE CONF
something and build an opinion about it, and then it
asks you in the IRAT, well, in two steps, by
NOTE CONF
doing the pre-reading and then doing the IRAT, you individually
make a judgement and come to a decision.
NOTE CONF
Then your next step is to defend that to a
small group of trusted people.
NOTE CONF
And maybe take on some of their points of view,
so it'd be a wider view, some flexibility, but we
NOTE CONF
pick a group you work with all term.
And who hopefully you have a decent relationship with.
NOTE CONF
And then the next step is to go further out
into a bigger, wider, scarier world where the teacher is
NOTE CONF
hearing your answer and the other people in the class
are hearing your answer, but you've got more back-up cos
NOTE CONF
you've got all your teammates behind you and you get
another layer of getting into the material and expanding your
NOTE CONF
possibilities and then after that, the big task comes.
You should, it's kind of priming you to be open
NOTE CONF
to ideas, it's priming you to know the material we're
thinking about.
NOTE CONF
It's priming you to work with your teammates just before
we hit you with what's supposed to be a relatively
NOTE CONF
difficult task to get done in an hour.
So we want you like, Like in top form, top
NOTE CONF
teammate form.
Top team operation form to be able to take on
NOTE CONF
the application activity that we give you.
I think it was I did, I did one of
NOTE CONF
those classes today and it worked well.
Um, and as always with the first class there was
NOTE CONF
a team or two who just didn't really want to
talk to each other, but by the end they were
NOTE CONF
chatting away.
Two of them found out that they're from the same
NOTE CONF
part of the world and they were discussing the best
place to get waffles or something, I don't know which
NOTE CONF
part of the world is on waffles, but whatever.
Does anyone know which part of the world likes waffles
NOTE CONF
the best?
Not, they never went about.
NOTE CONF
OK.
All right.
NOTE CONF
Do we have questions on team-based learning before I move
on, off it?
NOTE CONF
You'll get it in your workshops, it'll be fun.
OK.
NOTE CONF
Well, my slides tell me that next I'm talking about
domain specific languages.
NOTE CONF
Alright, so uh let's do a rundown of different languages
you know, how many different languages can you have you
NOTE CONF
actually programmed in?
So, some, uh, I, I know that uh the quiet
NOTE CONF
person doesn't want to talk to me, say you have
programmed in Java, right?
NOTE CONF
There you go, so you can say Java.
Java.
NOTE CONF
Now what's another language we've programmed in?
C.
NOTE CONF
Python C, just for fun presumably.
Oh no, in the games course, right?
NOTE CONF
Ah Oh, you studied in UTAS.
C, I have also programmed in C because it was
NOTE CONF
the best way to get access to the DirectX API
in 2003.
NOTE CONF
Next.
Processing, yes, which is a a variant of Java, but
NOTE CONF
that's, I think it is a separate language, yes.
JavaScript, yes, if you're on our web.
NOTE CONF
TypeScript, which is an extension of JavaScript or a superset
of JavaScript, 8 X86 assembler.
NOTE CONF
That's fun, hm.
Uh, which one?
NOTE CONF
I don't know that one.
Spell it.
NOTE CONF
F U C K.
00, OK, yeah, yeah, yeah.
NOTE CONF
Brain F K.
Yes, which is a language that uses the minimum number
NOTE CONF
of syntax tokens, so it's almost impossible to read.
I believe there are 4 or 6 different operations, but
NOTE CONF
it is a fun intellectual exercise.
I would recommend white space as an equivalent intellectual exercise.
NOTE CONF
Every programme in white space is just white space, tabs
and spaces and whatever else is in there, and so
NOTE CONF
every programme looks blank, but they all do things.
It's a very trolley language, yes.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
Go, nice, which is still, it go survived, Go's popularity
NOTE CONF
hasn't dropped off like some of its contemporaries have.
So we got a Python.
NOTE CONF
Lua, I love it.
Lua's a great language, what were you using that for?
NOTE CONF
I lure in Roblox, ah, that's brilliant.
Oh no, that's great.
NOTE CONF
I approve of both of those things.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
SWIFT, which is Apple's language for writing applications on Mac
OS and iOS.
NOTE CONF
If I remember, I used the C+ make She's a
It's, it's used for us, there's a specific like game
NOTE CONF
maker.
Oh, I didn't think I've seen that one, that's new
NOTE CONF
to me.
It's very good.
NOTE CONF
I, I go pretty obscure.
PP PHP, yes, I've written PHP as well.
NOTE CONF
I didn't mind PHP.
Everyone else hates it.
NOTE CONF
I don't mind it.
Do we have any PhP apps left at the university?
NOTE CONF
I don't think we do.
Alright, so we've gotten a big spread of languages, there's
NOTE CONF
something all of the, did you have one?
No?
NOTE CONF
Something.
B O L C.
NOTE CONF
B O L T bolt.
Oh, I don't know that one.
NOTE CONF
I'm afraid to just look up random things while I'm
projecting, but Ah, I'd like to know more, look it
NOTE CONF
up, Bolt.
Tell me more.
NOTE CONF
I actually Yes, it's true.
No, I'm not doing it.
NOTE CONF
Did you find anything about?
High level middle language with a bridge licence.
NOTE CONF
It aims to combine the best parts of other swiming
environments.
NOTE CONF
While we Alright, sounds like it's got a domain that
I don't know about.
NOTE CONF
Very good, you found one, we've got two that I
didn't know about.
NOTE CONF
So that one probably is a domain specific language as
well, but the other ones that we've discussed are all
NOTE CONF
what's called general purpose languages.
They're languages that you can use for just about anything.
NOTE CONF
And mostly when we learn programming languages, those are the
ones we focus on because we want our skills to
NOTE CONF
be as broad as possible.
But a very powerful and important subset of programming languages
NOTE CONF
go under the title Domain Specific Languages, and what they
are, are somewhat smaller, simpler, focused on a particular task.
NOTE CONF
And it allows people who operate only in that domain
not to have to know every single thing about every
NOTE CONF
single programming language, not to have to try and use
some clunky, awkward object system to represent something that's got
NOTE CONF
a better mechanism underneath.
To get their job done And there are domain specific
NOTE CONF
languages all over the place that comes under examples.
But this is also my chance to talk about compilers
NOTE CONF
and interpreters, which is something that comes up a little
bit through the course.
NOTE CONF
So we went through, well first of all, who knows
what who can give me a difference between compilers versus
NOTE CONF
interpreters?
Yep, yep, so compiler is uh The software to turn
NOTE CONF
your code into Something like bicycle, that machine can run
immediately without any Our translation.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise, interpreter is like.
The software is that read your code and run it
NOTE CONF
like.
Line by line.
NOTE CONF
The thing that the CP run run directly.
Yeah, that's a good explanation.
NOTE CONF
And a compiler.
Sorry, I'm just trying to work out why this can't
NOTE CONF
see my.
A compiler converts your code into something the computer can
NOTE CONF
run directly, an interpreter tends to run your code line
by line.
NOTE CONF
I'm just trying to bring up my um iPad here
so I can scribble and draw something down.
NOTE CONF
And it was Kapila reads everything.
foreign all the Interpreters play as you go is a
NOTE CONF
good way to describe it.
But what I'm gonna put down on my notes here
NOTE CONF
is that there's kind of a spectrum between them, there's
not really one or the other.
NOTE CONF
Um, if I can get the iPad to show up
here.
NOTE CONF
I have to stare at my own face while I
do this.
NOTE CONF
Why isn't the iPad showing up?
That's infuriating.
NOTE CONF
Alright, I'll have to do it the old-fashioned way then.
I've gotta get that working for next time.
NOTE CONF
Just try once more.
Hello.
NOTE CONF
OK, I got my notes up.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So it's, we're writing an interpreter in this course.
So the difference between compilers and interpreters is theoretically interesting
NOTE CONF
to us, um, but once we get started on our
actual implementation, we're doing just an interpreter, which is why
NOTE CONF
we do right at the start a discussion of the
difference.
NOTE CONF
How do I get rid of that stupid thing Is
that just going to stick there the whole time?
NOTE CONF
What do I You can still see what I'm doing.
I'll chase that another day.
NOTE CONF
Not good Uh, so I wanted to go through those
languages to help you get a, a feel for what
NOTE CONF
a compiler versus an interpreter is, but I, I think
it's easier to draw a diagram.
NOTE CONF
So, When I write my source code.
That's my Icon for a file Somewhere over here to
NOTE CONF
the right is a computer.
That's my picture of a computer, see, I'm used to
NOTE CONF
old CRT screens, pizza box.
The file, the programme I write is in the file.
NOTE CONF
Excuse me.
In my thinner days, I write the file.
NOTE CONF
And then ultimately it's the computer that has to run.
The programme, correct?
NOTE CONF
We're happy with that?
So somewhere in between the file I write and the
NOTE CONF
computer running the programme, some stuff has to happen.
So one possibility is that there's a programme inside the
NOTE CONF
computer called the compiler.
Which takes my file.
NOTE CONF
And makes a different file.
That the computer likes better.
NOTE CONF
And then the computer says, I love that kind of
file, I can just run that directly.
NOTE CONF
So, it does.
Ultimately, There could be a programme inside the computer called
NOTE CONF
an interpreter.
Which just takes a single line at a time and
NOTE CONF
pumps it through to the computer.
One at a time.
NOTE CONF
And says please run this line for me.
Now that you've done that, please run the next line
NOTE CONF
for me.
OK, positives and negatives.
NOTE CONF
What, what even is the positive of the interpreter?
You think that it, it, from my diagram, it feels
NOTE CONF
like the compiler's way quicker.
It just looks at the whole programme, converts it, and
NOTE CONF
we're done.
With Every line, every library has to get it all
NOTE CONF
ready collect it all.
Whereas with the interpreter, you can just start by doing.
NOTE CONF
It's exactly right.
Quick, it's quick to start.
NOTE CONF
The compiler, there's not just one file in my programme,
there are thousands.
NOTE CONF
There's the, the, the 15 or so I wrote, plus
all of the libraries I'm linking in and the files
NOTE CONF
everywhere, the compiler's actually got a lot of work to
do.
NOTE CONF
To make that final thing.
So slow to start, quick to run.
NOTE CONF
Interpreters tend to be quick to start, slow to run.
OK, so you can all imagine from your your workflow
NOTE CONF
as developers that there are times where you like something
that's quick to start cos it keeps you on a
NOTE CONF
nice tight loop.
That's one reason to want interpreters.
NOTE CONF
So you can think of it just as a straight
trade-off.
NOTE CONF
One of them, like I said, uh, slow to start
faster run versus faster run.
NOTE CONF
Fast to start, slow to run.
There's another trade-off though.
NOTE CONF
Which is that compilers are much more complicated machines than
interpreters.
NOTE CONF
So you the complex at the top, simpler at the
bottom.
NOTE CONF
So that might answer the reason why we're writing an
interpreter.
NOTE CONF
As opposed to writing a compiler.
But we are not restricting ourselves just to interpreters because
NOTE CONF
it turns out that there's actually 1000 shades of grey
in between these guys.
NOTE CONF
You could start from an interpreter and change a thing
here and change a thing there and make it into
NOTE CONF
a compiler.
You can go the opposite way, you can start from
NOTE CONF
a compiler and put a bit here and put a
bit there and before you know it you've got an
NOTE CONF
interpreter.
There's just a complete gradation between the two.
NOTE CONF
The first thing you can imagine you can imagine is
like.
NOTE CONF
Just reading line by line.
Your interpreter would compile would like translate the whole file,
NOTE CONF
yeah, the whole function, yeah, that's right.
Yeah, well I'll I'll give you a great example of
NOTE CONF
one where interpreters very quickly decide they have to write
the whole, read the whole file before they start.
NOTE CONF
So an interpreter by rights goes line by line.
If you've got a programme with function through up there.
NOTE CONF
And function bar down here.
Function f can't call function bar.
NOTE CONF
In a real honest to God interpreter.
Because ba hasn't even been defined.
NOTE CONF
By the time you try and call it.
You're in the middle of food and it says run
NOTE CONF
bar and you're like, I haven't seen any bar, I
don't know what you're talking about bar.
NOTE CONF
So like day dot interpreters start reading the entire file,
just for that reason.
NOTE CONF
Um, so we immediately start down that path, but conceptually
these are the differences between the two.
NOTE CONF
And somewhere in between there.
Our interpreter fits versus our compiler fits.
NOTE CONF
Now for us personally, And where most real interpreters fit.
Is that they, yes they do read the whole file.
NOTE CONF
They do read all your files.
But that's all they do to them, they literally just
NOTE CONF
read them into an internal slightly changed format and then
start executing them.
NOTE CONF
That way they can reference things.
Whereas compilers will do that same step of reading it
NOTE CONF
into an internal form and then start mashing on that
form.
NOTE CONF
And changing it and converting it and optimising it and
fiddling with it.
NOTE CONF
And type checking on it.
And all kinds of That's exactly right.
NOTE CONF
One's on the fly, one does all the pre-work, and
then it's done.
NOTE CONF
But really important you understand that there's a gradation because
you're gonna look at our interpreter and go, seems to
NOTE CONF
do a lot of work before it runs.
And what I'm saying to you is, yes, yes, yes,
NOTE CONF
but there's way more work that could be getting done.
the Well, that's where we, where we draw the line
NOTE CONF
is.
If the the the the.
NOTE CONF
In practise, the definition between compiler and interpreter is what's
the output.
NOTE CONF
If a compiler, if somebody outputs another programme.
We probably call it a compiler.
NOTE CONF
If it never outputs anything and just keeps running, then
we probably call it an interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Yeah But that that none of these rules are hard
and fast.
NOTE CONF
OK.
It's often.
NOTE CONF
Squiggly.
OK.
NOTE CONF
OK, cool.
Now, domain-specific languages.
NOTE CONF
Very rarely have compilers.
From what I've told you so far, can you guess
NOTE CONF
why that might be?
No, that's true.
NOTE CONF
That's a part of it.
Well, I gave you two trade-offs between the two, compiler's
NOTE CONF
more complex.
Interpret it simpler Compiler starts slow, runs fast, interpreter starts
NOTE CONF
fast, runs slow.
On both of those trade-offs, domain specific languages tend to
NOTE CONF
sit on the interpreter side.
Speed is very rarely a concern for them in terms
NOTE CONF
of execution, and they're in restrictive domains, so there's not
a lot of resources to be put into building a
NOTE CONF
compiler for them.
The fastest option is the best option.
NOTE CONF
A good domain specific language, they.
There's good reasons to have domain specific languages with thousands
NOTE CONF
of users, not millions, or tens of millions.
And so you can't put a lot of effort to
NOTE CONF
building a compiler just to support a few 1000 users,
but interpreters are quick and easy to write.
NOTE CONF
So you can always fire up an interpreter and give
them all the facilities they need, they're never gonna notice
NOTE CONF
that it's not as fast as it could possibly be,
because as we're gonna see, domain specific languages tend to
NOTE CONF
do one small job that is not, A difficult job
And that's what we're doing, we're writing a domain specific
NOTE CONF
language.
Let's talk a little about Turing completeness.
NOTE CONF
Does someone know what that phrase means?
Tur incompleteness.
NOTE CONF
No, it was, it's, yeah, so he asked us about
the Turing test.
NOTE CONF
Same person but different domain.
I'll explain the tune to separately.
NOTE CONF
OK, so one of the things about general purpose language
is, what makes them general purpose is that they're all
NOTE CONF
equivalent to each other.
So if I asked you to write something in Python
NOTE CONF
and I asked you to write something in Java, you
wouldn't feel at a disadvantage.
NOTE CONF
You could they'd, you'd be like, well, cool, off I
go.
NOTE CONF
They, these languages are both as powerful as each other.
And that's true for every general purpose language.
NOTE CONF
There's a specific mathematical hurdle once the language jumps that
in terms of power.
NOTE CONF
It can do anything that any other language can do.
And that hurdle is called Turing completeness.
NOTE CONF
It's a mathematical concept more than a programming one, but
for us as programmers, we will think of all of
NOTE CONF
our general purpose languages definitely as Turing complete.
No one would accept a general purpose language that wasn't.
NOTE CONF
But domain specific languages sometimes aren't.
Turing complete, meaning they sometimes are computations they can't do
NOTE CONF
because it's just doesn't matter, it's outside their domain.
The simplicity, the solution in the context is what's valuable
NOTE CONF
more than the power of the means perfect marriage.
But Du incompleteness turns out to be such an easy
NOTE CONF
hurdle to jump that most of them end up doing
it anyway, by accident.
NOTE CONF
If not by accident, then on purpose.
Um, so a lot of domain specific languages will turn
NOTE CONF
out to be Turing incomplete, and it's quite fun seeing
the mechanisms by which they become Turing-complete because you're looking
NOTE CONF
at it going, I can't see how this could do
everything Java could do.
NOTE CONF
And then someone shows you and you're like, Still don't
see it, but at least I believe you now.
NOTE CONF
OK, and the Turing test, it was the same guy,
Alan Turing, once he'd already invented programming, he started to
NOTE CONF
think about artificial intelligence and made up his own test
for whether an AI was.
NOTE CONF
Yeah and his test was kind of through a telephone
line.
NOTE CONF
If a comp if if, if yeah, can you determine
if you're talking to a computer or a human?
NOTE CONF
And if you can't then we'll call it intelligence and
there was.
NOTE CONF
For the 1st 50 years of computing, that was fun,
but AI is kind of just swamped all over that.
NOTE CONF
And we think of very different things.
But like, but all the things that pass the Turing
NOTE CONF
test actually we don't want to think of as intelligent.
So it has been slightly, slightly uh overtaken.
NOTE CONF
OK.
So let's look at some DSLs.
NOTE CONF
What's on my list here?
Sequel, Redjes, HTML, Make Lax and Strudel.
NOTE CONF
Strudel's a fun one.
So, hm?
NOTE CONF
So the ones you might have played with before, well
I hope you would have by this point in your
NOTE CONF
course, at least to SQL, SQL is a domain specific
language for pulling data from relational databases.
NOTE CONF
If you try and think to yourself, how would I
do what I do in SQL in a language like
NOTE CONF
Java.
It's not nice.
NOTE CONF
And there are entire fields of computer science devoted to
trying to make Java or a general purpose language feel
NOTE CONF
as good as SQL does for pulling data from a
relational database and it's just a failed effort over 30
NOTE CONF
years.
The, it, it is the right language for the task
NOTE CONF
at hand.
And so people keep backing down to it because it's
NOTE CONF
so much easier to think in that language.
Here's a key thing that I want you to know
NOTE CONF
about programming.
Programmers need to be able to fit.
NOTE CONF
Most of their programme in their head.
And so A really efficient way of describing your programme
NOTE CONF
is super valuable for a programmer, cos it expands the
set of things that they can understand at once.
NOTE CONF
That's what happens with domain specific languages.
The crust starts to go away.
NOTE CONF
And you can fit more in your head.
Anyone else used any of these others?
NOTE CONF
HTML, a lot of people use HTML.
Well, I, I don't know who wrote this.
NOTE CONF
I mean, I gave some of this work to OpenCode,
it might have, might have written this, I should have
NOTE CONF
uh checked it more carefully.
HTML's not a bloody language.
NOTE CONF
Not a programming language at all, it doesn't belong in
there.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, but it's not a programming language, it is a
markup language.
NOTE CONF
So HTML actually doesn't have computation in it at all.
It's not a programming language.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna take that out.
uh commence Yeah Dreammaker.
NOTE CONF
All right, I'll do it.
Where are you, come 3000, lecture rundown.
NOTE CONF
Um You have, well, you all will be all through
every student who comes through contributes, but yes.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
Is it one word?
NOTE CONF
Dream space makeup DM is the app.
Uh Do you have any I Sunday through which they
NOTE CONF
interact with.
Nice.
NOTE CONF
The graphical OK, now in the workshops.
Next week I'm actually getting a tiny bit ahead here,
NOTE CONF
uh, you'll be playing with rejects.
There's another markup language on this list, you can see
NOTE CONF
the other markup language.
Lach.
NOTE CONF
Why am I leaving latech up there when I took
HTML off?
NOTE CONF
I can actually do computation.
Um, lateTC is something that just tried to be a
NOTE CONF
markup language, didn't plan to be a programming language, and
turned out to be true and complete.
NOTE CONF
And this happens a lot.
When you create a system that people use, they, they
NOTE CONF
just naturally fall towards full computational ability because it's such
a powerful thing.
NOTE CONF
Make is a programming language for writing compiler steps.
So in Java you might have used Maven.
NOTE CONF
Um, every language tends to have its own.
Make was built way back in the olden days of
NOTE CONF
C.
So it's mostly focused on C compilation.
NOTE CONF
It tells you which files have to be compiled for
which other files to work.
NOTE CONF
Um And it again turns out to be true incomplete,
and all they wanted to do was say, if I'm
NOTE CONF
compiling this file, do I need, which header files do
I need, right?
NOTE CONF
Now strudel's a fun one, which I want you guys
to.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, no, we don't have to cos I, I hopefully
already have it.
NOTE CONF
This is to show off the kind of fun things
you can do with domain specifically and see if my
NOTE CONF
audio's working again.
OK, it's a little bit louder than I hoped, but
NOTE CONF
I can talk over it.
So this is a demo of a domain specific language
NOTE CONF
for making music.
It's a very simple example here, it's just a couple
NOTE CONF
of drumbeats that is going over and over, but I
the the the demo's nice because you can see how
NOTE CONF
the domain specific language is, is describing something potentially quite
complex.
NOTE CONF
In a programming language form.
In a very short form, and because it's, it's got
NOTE CONF
the execution on top of it, we can actually understand
it.
NOTE CONF
That's star 2 by the way, has got to do
with the tempo.
NOTE CONF
Um, I don't know what changing it will do, but
I could try it.
NOTE CONF
And so this bit here defines a sound, S.
And a sound is multiple sounds in a row, and
NOTE CONF
when they put them through the pointy parentheses, it says
do the first one, then the second one and alternate
NOTE CONF
between them, and so that's what it's doing.
And then you can change the tempo of the sound.
NOTE CONF
And I, then you can tell it which sound library
to go to.
NOTE CONF
To pull the sounds out, we might try and find
some other sound libraries to try out.
NOTE CONF
Anyway, so it reads like a, well it doesn't, this
one doesn't read hugely like a piece of text.
NOTE CONF
It kind of reads like.
Um, cryptic gobbledygook, but once you get into it.
NOTE CONF
Not, you don't spend too much time with it before
you're, it's the language you can use to describe a
NOTE CONF
programme, uh describe a a piece of music.
And strudel gets arbitrarily complex and it's been so much
NOTE CONF
fun that people make TikToks about it, which is how
it came to our attention.
NOTE CONF
Um, Various TikToks of people making programmes and the programmes
expand and the sound comes in and you can watch
NOTE CONF
it happen, it's really good fun, yes.
Well, Well, I think I know how Strudel came to
NOTE CONF
be, but that could have been it, but no.
In fact, Strudel is, this is a a good knot
NOTE CONF
of programming language stuff.
One of the programming languages no one mentioned is Haskell.
NOTE CONF
Which is a very popular language with programming language nerds,
and they love to show off cool programming language things.
NOTE CONF
But what happened was someone learned Haskal and then went,
how cool is programming, I have to show someone else
NOTE CONF
how cool programming is.
I'm gonna make a music language in high school.
NOTE CONF
I get to try out my high school skills, which
is good fun, and I get to invent a new
NOTE CONF
language, which is good fun, and it makes other people
see how cool programming languages are.
NOTE CONF
So it's a big knot of recursion, where a love
for programming and a knowledge of music came together and
NOTE CONF
they just built a programming language in their programming language
because we heard you love programming languages, and this was
NOTE CONF
their particular domain.
Yep So are they linked to a, it's probably not
NOTE CONF
linked to a server, it's probably always downloaded by the
website when I go to it.
NOTE CONF
But um, This here is a model of a synthesiser
or something, right, or.
NOTE CONF
Sound machine, so I can change it out to get
the different sounds.
NOTE CONF
I don't know exactly under the hood, exactly how the,
the website works, but it, it's to give you a
NOTE CONF
flavour of how the language is.
How a domain specific language wants to operate and how
NOTE CONF
the conciseness of the domain specific language is a big
win, I think.
NOTE CONF
Another key part of this though.
So this describes music.
NOTE CONF
There's already a language for describing music, isn't there?
It's, you've all seen sheet music.
NOTE CONF
But what's the big downside of sheet music?
It's not in Latin scripts Yeah, I can't type it
NOTE CONF
on my computer and the computer can't really read it
either.
NOTE CONF
It's not in the language that me and computers talk
to each other in.
NOTE CONF
The language that me and computers talk to each other
in is Asy text.
NOTE CONF
OK, and so the uh a domain specific language is
almost always in ASci text.
NOTE CONF
Even when there's an existing already perfectly good language, we
might go, yeah, yeah, sure, whatever.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna make an ASci text version, now me and
the computer can talk to each other and that's when
NOTE CONF
the real fun's gonna happen.
So your language, this is a very terse language.
NOTE CONF
It's using the minimum number of things to say the
maximum number of stuff.
NOTE CONF
The language you're gonna write, I don't, I don't want
you to go down the terse route.
NOTE CONF
I prefer if you go down the verbose route, verbose
route, uh, because those tends to be a bit easier
NOTE CONF
to read.
Um.
NOTE CONF
Are there any other languages I can play here?
Uh, any other strings of, no, it doesn't seem to
NOTE CONF
give me any off the top of the head, oops.
Just give me the one demo Alright, I'll have to
NOTE CONF
look up a more fun demo.
Feel free to post on the forums if you come
NOTE CONF
up with a fun Strudel programme for others to run.
Even though this is it, we don't see Strudel again,
NOTE CONF
it was just a one-off fun thing.
What we will see next week is red checks, which
NOTE CONF
are very, very important.
The main specific language, you probably, who's used reeds before?
NOTE CONF
Just 1234, yeah.
We'll use them a lot more because they are the
NOTE CONF
domain-specific language for operating on text.
And as programmers, we do a lot of operating on
NOTE CONF
text.
And your interpreter is operating on text.
NOTE CONF
It reads in text, it spits out text.
There's every chance you'll have a few rejects in the
NOTE CONF
middle of your interpreter.
And so, that's the one we focus on learning more
NOTE CONF
about, yeah?
Yes, so the question was, does that limit the type
NOTE CONF
of grammars?
I'm not suggesting you're using rejects for parsing.
NOTE CONF
I'm suggesting in your parser, it might use a few
rejects to help.
NOTE CONF
In its task.
We use a proper parser which is called a recursive
NOTE CONF
descent parser, that can do all of the grammars.
It's a really good point though.
NOTE CONF
Rejectas are a super concise and neat way to pull
out bits of text, and rejects are true incomplete.
NOTE CONF
But they're not, they are.
The 2 and complete means there's not restrictions.
NOTE CONF
But it's not the right tool for the full job
that a compiler does.
NOTE CONF
So the compiler, we're gonna learn about that.
That's week 4, passes.
NOTE CONF
OK, uh, but, uh, the, the, the part of that
I forgot about halfway through the sentence was what we're
NOTE CONF
doing is we're learning rejects, which is the super simple
nice to mean specific language, which is a skill on
NOTE CONF
its own, and then we're levelling that up to recursive
descent pases which do exactly anything we want with text.
NOTE CONF
And that's a skill, even if we're not writing an
interpreter, knowing how to write a parser gives us complete
NOTE CONF
control of text that's going into our computer.
We basically become the conductors of text.
NOTE CONF
Why build a DSL?
Well, when it's too much is really the answer.
NOTE CONF
We don't build it when a GP general purpose language
isn't enough, we build it when general purpose language is
NOTE CONF
too much.
It's a fun intellectual exercise.
NOTE CONF
Think about if you were to write a Java programme
to represent some music, how much of the screen it
NOTE CONF
would take up.
And how difficult it might be for someone just who
NOTE CONF
wasn't a programmer to understand.
I didn't say that earlier, but domain-specific languages are often
NOTE CONF
used by non-programmers.
I think that's unfair because once you're using a programming
NOTE CONF
language, you are a programmer, but you know what I
mean?
NOTE CONF
They're not otherwise a programmer.
This is the only type of programming that they do.
NOTE CONF
I guess.
Because it makes Mhm.
NOTE CONF
That's why you're here because when you have Those people
take those control right they they know what's in the
NOTE CONF
middle.
They get more semantic knowledge about fewer characters.
NOTE CONF
Exactly.
I Yeah Yep, that's a good point.
NOTE CONF
More semantic, and you've reminded me of something else which
is also the structure programmers ended up with in programming
NOTE CONF
languages turned out, turns out to be a really great.
The word we use is composition.
NOTE CONF
Composing, so.
The fact that Programmers are absolutely used to the fact
NOTE CONF
that that's a sound, and maybe I can.
I, I wanna do a I'm going around in circles
NOTE CONF
and spins.
That's a sound object in some sense, but I want
NOTE CONF
to modify that so that there, it could be from
the TR 909 or it could be from the TR
NOTE CONF
910, um.
The machinery programmers have used over the years is the
NOTE CONF
right machinery for taking a small thing and expanding its
capabilities.
NOTE CONF
Um, and so once you start to think on a,
once you open up the possibilities of a programming language.
NOTE CONF
To someone who's used to just a domain, you broaden
their horizons hugely.
NOTE CONF
Alright, that was probably a little bit too esoteric to
make sense, but I felt I had to say it.
NOTE CONF
OK, 6:42.
Let's, let's, let's wrap this up.
NOTE CONF
Let's just give you a teaser on.
Well, I already showed you in the textbook.
NOTE CONF
Um But it's this mountain here It's a little bit
small there, isn't it?
NOTE CONF
So he tries to represent, 00, before I go on,
the grafting interpreters book has two parts, a Java part
NOTE CONF
and a C part.
We are only doing the Java part, the C part
NOTE CONF
is for you to do for fun later and we're
not even doing the full Java part.
NOTE CONF
There'll be a spot we stop at.
But this is like a map of what we're gonna
NOTE CONF
do.
Starts at source code.
NOTE CONF
Down here.
And we're going to scan into tokens and we're going
NOTE CONF
to pause into an abstract syntax tree.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
And so we're kind of gonna get to this point,
abstract syntax tree and the tree walk interpreter.
NOTE CONF
We will touch a little bit on the analysis and
optimisation ideas.
NOTE CONF
But we won't be going into transpiring.
Well, high level language is down at the start because
NOTE CONF
your source code is a high level language.
And we won't be going much into code generation.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so what was I gonna do?
Oh, I'm gonna, um, define a few of these words
NOTE CONF
just so you've got the context for them.
OK.
NOTE CONF
So we talked about interpreting and compiling.
When you're right down the middle and your audience can't
NOTE CONF
decide if you're an interpreter or a compiler, they call
you a transpier.
NOTE CONF
So, that word just means somewhere in between an interpreter
and a compiler.
NOTE CONF
What it really means I think is it's a compiler
that compiles from one high level language to another high
NOTE CONF
level language.
Whereas a normal compiler can pass from a high level
NOTE CONF
language to something like X86 or AR assembler or a
bytecode.
NOTE CONF
It's possible to write compilers that compile Java into Python,
for example.
NOTE CONF
That would be cool to transpire, yeah.
Uh, IR is is, well, I'll go through those.
NOTE CONF
There are 3 main structures inside a compiler slash interpreter.
You get the original source code at one end and
NOTE CONF
the machine code at the other end.
We transform source code first into a form called tokens,
NOTE CONF
and we will learn that in week 3.
Then we transform tokens into an abstract syntax tree, which
NOTE CONF
we learned in week 5.
And we don't do it in this course, but it's
NOTE CONF
an option to convert convert the abstract syntax tree into
an intermediate representation, IR.
NOTE CONF
Which more advanced compilers use for some of their tasks.
So we only go as far as abstract syntax tree,
NOTE CONF
AST in this course.
But IR stands for intermediate representation.
NOTE CONF
Analysis is the job of, it's, it's like a type
system.
NOTE CONF
Type system is one of the forms of analysis we
do on a programme.
NOTE CONF
You'll be familiar with the type system, but it's possible
to do other very powerful forms of analysis like data
NOTE CONF
flow analysis as well.
From the diagram you can see they get done after
NOTE CONF
the abstract syntax tree.
optimising is whenever you take a programme and don't change
NOTE CONF
anything about what it does, but somehow make it run
faster.
NOTE CONF
Um, that very rarely happens on the abstract syntax tree,
it's much more likely to happen on the intermediate representation.
NOTE CONF
We will actually touch on a few, probably opttimisations, just
to show you a flavour of what an optimisation looks
NOTE CONF
like.
But for example, it's possible in a programme to um.
NOTE CONF
In the process of compiling a programme to find out
that X is being added to 0.
NOTE CONF
And you can go, oh well, I just don't have
to do that then, do I?
NOTE CONF
X + 0 is the same as X.
That's an optimisation.
NOTE CONF
And you're like that should be obvious to the programmer,
but during the compilation, during these transformations, some things surfaced
NOTE CONF
that weren't visible in the original programme, so the compiler
gets a chance to make a decision there.
NOTE CONF
The programmer didn't get to.
Um, and then there's two down the bottom, bytecode and
NOTE CONF
machine code, are kind of the two normal targets that
a compiler will go with.
NOTE CONF
Machine code is the the low level stuff that that
your chip knows what to do with.
NOTE CONF
Bytecode is a, it's a slightly strange intermediate thing, we
don't have to think about all that much in this
NOTE CONF
course, I might just drop that for now and come
back to it later.
NOTE CONF
If we have to, when we get into those theoretical
topics, but one way, uh, the best way to, nah
NOTE CONF
I'll just explain it, the best way to think of
it is that you made up your own machine code
NOTE CONF
cos you didn't like any of the ones that existed.
And uh that sounds stupid but the all of your,
NOTE CONF
anyone who's got a Mac, it's running on a bytecode
called LLVM.
NOTE CONF
Um, that has made the max way faster.
By being a bytecode, they have a strange, strange kind
NOTE CONF
of mystical ability to do things that they shouldn't be
able to do.
NOTE CONF
Bytecodes are fun, and Java goes to a bytecode as
well, so if you're programme in Java, you're in bytecode
NOTE CONF
land, if you're sitting with a Mac or and then
you're in bytecode land as well.
NOTE CONF
All right.
More than enough for 5 to 7 on a Monday
NOTE CONF
night.
Thank you for coming by to keep me busy, to
NOTE CONF
keep me company.
Any questions before we disappear?
NOTE CONF
Yes lights give us I To say exactly which bits
of the book to read, yes.
NOTE CONF
Yep, weeks ahead.
It's convener's job to do that.
NOTE CONF
So we'll have to ask Lockie, chuck it on the
forums, and I would say if you have a preference,
NOTE CONF
ask for that preference.
Instead of just saying, what will you give us, say,
NOTE CONF
can you please give us.
bringing And not Now, the text is, the text is
NOTE CONF
enough, all the self-study exercises come from the text.
Not for this week, this week for your workshop classes
NOTE CONF
you don't have anything to do except turn up to
the lecture which you've done.
NOTE CONF
But in the future weeks, they will be released, and
you'll be able to see them ahead of time because.
NOTE CONF
The This is not official, it's not been released yet,
we haven't double-checked it, but, Um, this is what next
NOTE CONF
week's look like.
It says please do.
NOTE CONF
Well, that's definitely gonna change because we're not doing the
recordings on Echo 360 anymore, but that's the kind of
NOTE CONF
text you see for each week.
Read this thing, do these things before you come to
NOTE CONF
class, yeah?
Uh, teams, uh, can, um, organise the way they want.
NOTE CONF
It's a team thing though, so.
If you've got a strong idea and then you're with
NOTE CONF
5 other people that don't want to do it.
Drop it, but if you can talk them in like
NOTE CONF
if you think it's a good idea and they think
it's a good idea, absolutely go for it.
NOTE CONF
I already did it in today's class.
The teams came up with all different ways to organise
NOTE CONF
themselves.
Uh, team organization's weigh more about the members themselves than
NOTE CONF
anything I might impose on them, yep.
And the teams all have different personalities.
NOTE CONF
Workshop is when you'll be put into your teams, yep.
I'll give you a hot tip, do you want the
NOTE CONF
hot tip?
I'll turn off the slides so these people don't get
NOTE CONF
the hot tip.
You're most likely to end up geographically team-based.
NOTE CONF
So when you walk into class, look for someone you
want to work with and sit next to them.
NOTE CONF
And then when the person makes the teams, probably the
fact that you're sitting next to them will help.
NOTE CONF
That's.
You could drop.
NOTE CONF
That also tends to keep friends groups together because they
tend to sit together.
NOTE CONF
No, Oh, I forgot to say, 5 to 7 class,
if you want to bring food and have your dinner
NOTE CONF
in class, that's fine as long as it doesn't smell
strong or is KFC because KFC makes me so hungry.
NOTE CONF
Oh, I guess.
Um was that your research association um I was wondering
NOTE CONF
if you've heard of uh guy.
It's you don't I I OK, but, um.
NOTE CONF
To, uh, now it's, uh, It's a game, um, it's
a switch.
NOTE CONF
It's, it's a big thing.
What are these games like?
NOTE CONF
Uh, well, Raid is a platform which has like OK,
um, to witness is it's a puzzle game where you.
NOTE CONF
It's very different kind of gave me a maze and
sometimes it's fun.
NOTE CONF
I just.
My year two is just pass, pass, pass.
NOTE CONF
15 for my second year and my my third year
I got 22 2060, 60, 65, 64 and then on
NOTE CONF
my first year I got I got two decisions.
I'm gonna, I'm going to find something that she too,
NOTE CONF
maybe.
Stars reception, reception IT support and then for 3 months,
NOTE CONF
4 months and then after that I go.
B.
NOTE CONF
Oh my gosh, they didn't see me the whole time.
you Are you also studying here?
NOTE CONF
I'm not quite sure.
I'm doing my now after this way, uh, after I
NOTE CONF
think still master it, huh.
After much I think I Oh you directly do the
NOTE CONF
master.
No, I'm doing bachelor.
NOTE CONF
After your bachelor you directly study master.
Huh, I think so.
NOTE CONF
I need to, I'm not too sure yet.
Maybe I will study, I study with my master here
NOTE CONF
or somehow I just get for 3 to 4 months
after that I will continue my master's, my second session.
NOTE CONF
It Bits of Nice ones also.
I check.
NOTE CONF
I 13,000 13 You want to see?
I want to buy a tutor next year.
NOTE CONF
one is you see which ones like a refurbish one
let me let me you know that's why you don't.
NOTE CONF
It's just normal.
You can see it back there That's why you see
NOTE CONF
red flags.
You see a magnet.
NOTE CONF
You see a back.
That's why you see the red thing.
NOTE CONF
It's my This Really?
Oh.
NOTE CONF
Oh, OK.
I saw my Malaysian friend and one Singaporean friend from
NOTE CONF
UNSW, one of them going go cycle.
Another one went omega.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I mean, people like my age now wearing watch
already, we don't see stuff, you see.
NOTE CONF
I'm watching and I mean people people like my age
are 23 already that's why we we play what's not
NOTE CONF
we didn't play.
My style is.
NOTE CONF
I mean, I buy, I buy my clothes, my stuff
every year.
NOTE CONF
I don't do it every month.
If I go buy my clothes, I usually buy it
NOTE CONF
for 4 years.
I think the last time, you know, I bought the
NOTE CONF
4 LB shoes because the money supposed to be my
father gave me supposed to I need to let $10,000
NOTE CONF
get me $10,000 to buy an Omega watch.
I didn't buy it, so I, I use it to
NOTE CONF
buy shoes for copay of $8000.
But, but it's shit, shit, shit.
NOTE CONF
I bought it already, but if I don't wear it,
it just go more.
NOTE CONF
And then next time, next year maybe I will just
get, get 3 pair of I send them back.
NOTE CONF
Alexander Mc, right?
I mean, just $1000 1500 dollars.
NOTE CONF
OK, I can wait.
Uh, I think I picked the wrong name.
NOTE CONF
Because that's 3,000s.
I didn't even learn 3000.
NOTE CONF
Well, did you learn when you started master session?
Yes, I haven't decided yet.
NOTE CONF
Opposition session.
It could be.
NOTE CONF
I want to be confident in the wrong way.
Just at the moment.
NOTE CONF
I'm lazy.
I've got my best.
NOTE CONF
Is this your minus 3 subjects?
Yeah, well, it depends.
NOTE CONF
I could go, right?
I can finish up after the semester.
NOTE CONF
Uh, this is my last treatment.
I'm we're quite safe, but in fact no sense.
NOTE CONF
This is my last year that's not the last.
I see is a project that we keep doing.
NOTE CONF
I think I'm not too sure yet, but.
because I need to decide before November.
NOTE CONF